So, we know that meditation is linked to overall feelings of well-being, but
does meditation only effect self reported changes in feelings? New research has
actually shown that meditation increases the growth of brain tissue in the
areas that are important in emotional processing and attention. In this study,
half of the people were trained in meditation and engaged in meditation for
eight weeks. The other half were randomly assigned to the control group, and
they did not meditate. At the end of the study, the changes in brain tissue
were also associated with emotional well-being in those that meditated. This
nicely demonstrates how changes in our environment can change our brain. So,
here's a question. Was the study I just talked about a correlational research
design or an experimental research design? Select one.